mr speaker the sugree report was
published this morning and i look
forward to discussing that during this
afternoon statement with the prime
minister
for now i want to focus on the cost of
living affecting the whole country
mr speaker since we stood here last week
and i asked the prime minister yet again
to back labor's plans for a windfall tax
to reduce energy bills
hundreds of millions of pounds have been
added to bills of families across the
country
and hundreds of millions of pounds have
landed in the bank accounts of energy
companies
it sounds like
he's finally seen sense
and the inevitable u-turn may finally
have arrived
so when can people across the country
expect him to use those oil and gas
profits to bring down their bills
[Applause]
well mr speaker there's nothing original
about a labour plan to tax uh businesses
nothing remar they want to tax business
uh the whole time every day uh labor
wants to put up taxes on business and
what we're doing is we're helping people
he asks when we're going to help people
yeah we're helping people now and mr
speaker and
we're we're putting 22 billion pounds
into uh people's pockets already cutting
uh council tax by 150 pounds cutting uh
fuel duty cutting national insurance
contributions by an average of 300 by an
average of 330 pounds for people who pay
for people who pay nicks and mr speaker
how can we afford that
because we have a strong economy because
we came out of covid fast mr speaker
which would not have been possible if we
listened to the party opposition
[Applause]
15 tax rises and he pretends they're a
low tax government
it's been it's been
mr speaker it's been four and a half
months since labor first called for a
windfall tax on oil and gas profits
i've raised it week in week out and
every week he has a new reason for not
doing it
the business secretary said it's bad the
justice secretary called it disastrous
yeah even this weekend the health
secretary and the northern ireland
secretary opposed it he ordered all of
his mps to vote against it last week
and now
surprise surprise
he's backing it
prime minister i'm told that hindsight
is a wonderful thing
[Applause]
but mr speaker
mr speaker
whilst he dithered and delayed
households across the country suffered
when they didn't need to
what
[Music]
you know
mr bull a man who always wants to catch
my eye he's not going the best way to do
so
mr speaker whilst he dithered and
delayed households across the country
suffered when they didn't need to
exactly
what is it about the sugray report that
first attracted him
to a u-turn this week
mr speaker mr speaker there's there is
there is no surprise
about labor's
lust there's no surprise about labour's
lust to put up taxes uh there's nothing
original about his thought they they get
off on it they they absolutely love to
confiscate other people's assets what we
prefer to do mr speaker is make sure
make sure that we have the measures that
are in place to drive investment in our
country and drive jobs and it's thanks
to the steps that we took thanks to the
fact that we came out of kobe faster
than any other other european country
which would not have been possible if we
listened uh to him uh that we that we
now have unemployment at the listen to
this they used to care about this mr
speaker unemployment at the lowest level
since 1974.
and
put that in your pipe pierced armor
mr speaker i actually thought with this
u-turn you might actually get his head
out of the sand but uh obviously not
the reality
is that every day of his dithering and
his delay 53 million pounds has been
added to britain's household bills
whilst he's distracted trying to save
his own job the country has been
counting the cost
but complacency is nothing new for this
government
back in october the chancellor delivered
a mini budget that has to be re-read to
be believed
with inflation already climbing
he said that he understood people were
concerned about it and the government
was ready to act
since then inflation has risen to a
40-year high the highest rate of any g7
country if the government was so ready
to act six months ago
why hasn't it
but mr speaker the government has acted
and my royal friend the chancellor
continues to act this is the government
that not only
we not only put in the living wage mr
speaker it was a conservative
institution uh but we've now raised it
by
raised it by a record amount we've
raised it by a thousand pounds uh mr
speaker a record of mine uh we've helped
people families on universal credit have
another 1 000 pounds mr speaker thanks
to the measures the 9.1 billion pounds
we've already put in uh to support
people's costs of heating we're abating
the cost of fuel for people up and down
the country and of course we're going to
do more mr speaker we're going to put
our arms around the people of this
country just as we did throughout the
kobe pandemic
but
but the reason we can do that is because
we took the tough decisions to drive the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe which
wouldn't have been possible if you
listen to him mr speaker and that's why
we have let me take another statistic
youth unemployment they used to care
about it youth unemployment at or near a
record
mr speaker it wasn't just the chancellor
back in september the prime minister
called fears about inflation unfounded
he was the last person to spot the cost
of living crisis
justice is the last person to back the
labour's plan to help people through it
and mr speaker it wasn't just on
inflation that they got it badly wrong
in the same speech the chancellor
boasted about growth prime minister does
today can we were going to do better
than all our major competitors it was
obvious that he was being complacent
yeah and lo and behold britain is set to
have the lowest growth of any major
country except russia
despite our brilliant businesses and all
we have to offer why has his government
inflicted on britain the twin-headed
hydra of the highest inflation and the
lowest growth